[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the Samsung Galaxy Note 7 it
came out a couple weeks ago but this is
everything you need to know about the
phone that I've used as my daily driver
since it drops so new points for the
Galaxy Note 7 are the design refresh
some camera improvements a bunch of new
software features and explosions let's
cover all of that so the new design is
something of a mix between the Galaxy s7
edge and the note 5 so plenty of glass
on the front and the back symmetrical on
the sides from front to back and curved
enough on both edges that it has what's
called a dual edge display so the glass
just kind of sort of melts over onto the
sides of the phone to the metal rails
and it's built extremely well honestly
between this and the galaxy s7 edge
Samsung seems to be on top of the build
quality game as far as smartphones go
right now it turns out to not be that
slippery thanks to the metal rails on
the side where your fingers rest you can
still drop a dbrand skin on the back to
show less fingerprints or add a bit more
grip on the back I'll leave a link to
them below
but yeah I'm overall pretty happy with
the build and the finish on the note 7
and the all-black is definitely my
favorite look there is a new blue coral
color and it kind of looks pretty neat
too a lot of people like it but I'm a
fan of the all-black look on pretty much
any smartphone so the only problem I
found with the dual edge display is
actually sometimes when I'm holding it I
don't realize that like part of my hand
is actually still touching the display
so it seems like it's unresponsive at
first but it's just because I'm holding
it wrong so that's my bad but it's just
in the way you hold it as far as what's
inside the note 7 it's pretty much using
the highest end parts available so
Snapdragon 820 4 gigabytes of RAM and up
front still an incredible quad HD Super
AMOLED display and let me just say this
is still what Samsung is doing best in
the business right now
other phones are getting better
technology in their displays and there
are some other great looking smart phone
displays right now but none of them
match this in my opinion the vividness
in the brightness in the sharpness and
color it just looks great it's one of
those phones where I would never have to
worry about being able to see it even
outdoors even when it's like sunny in
the car in a bright area
when brightness goes all the way up on
auto-brightness in a well-lit area it
really pushes the brightness so I can
always see the screen
even when I'm navigating or something
like that it's awesome so this is
hands-down the best display in a
smartphone and another thing that's
best-in-class on the note 7 is the
camera so it's brought up from the
galaxy s7 and s7 edge it's actually the
exact same camera from those phones so
the 12 megapixel sensor and f 1.7
aperture with optical image
stabilization all of thats come up and
when it first came out I would say it's
absolutely the best camera in any
smartphone now iPhone 7s come out since
then and it gets pretty close it has
some other novel features that make it
unique but still as an all-around camera
this is a huge selling point I have a
ton more photos from this camera since
I've gotten it and it's kind of because
it's one of those cameras that
encourages me to take a lot of photos
autofocus and actually opening the
camera app and snapping a photo are
super quick so it just feels easy to
take lots of photos and take lots of
great photos and this is basically a
continuation from how good it was in the
galaxy s7 as you can see great colors
great dynamic range for a smartphone
camera and excellent sharpness in detail
not too overdone or over-processed like
Samsung cameras used to be and just a
bigger phone overall actually kind of
makes it a bigger handle to take a photo
or video with so who knows I might even
help with stabilization so the photos
and 4k videos you get out of this phone
without even any editing or touch-ups
which you can do in a raw mode continue
to be really impressive now a big part
of what's made the note series
especially from the beginning when it
first came out a very popular phone with
power users like me is not only the fact
that it was always like a really big
phone but it just always had like all of
the latest all the best features that
Samsung's had to offer it's packed to
the gills with features it's got the S
Pen Stylus it's got multitasking with
multiple apps available at the same time
is basically doing everything it can to
take advantage of the high-end hardware
that you get so this phone is full of
the best that Samsung makes and to be
fair Samsung has done a really good job
of keeping a lot of the great features
in the phone without making a software
feel like overwhelming there used to be
just stuff everywhere
but it's pretty tame now it's actually a
little bit more organized so things are
a little bit easier to find this is a
search function in the settings app so
yeah a lot of neat features are tucked
in there
and they're not all screaming your face
they're just kind of waiting around the
corner
so one of the newest flashiest ones is
the iris scanner it's a new method for
unlocking your phone that takes
advantage of the new sensor in the top
of the phone along with an infrared
light blaster that you can actually see
in action when it's scanning and all it
wants you to do is basically hold the
phone up to your face for a second while
it reads your eyes to identify you and
then logs you in it kind of seems like
straight out of the future when it
actually works well as far as I know it
can't be fooled with photos of you or
other people's eyes I didn't think it's
quite as secure as other security
methods but despite me wearing contacts
which it says can impede it it works
really well in fact it actually seemed
to learn my eyes over time so a week
after setting this up iris scanning was
really fast I still prefer a fingerprint
reader though of course there are other
things like the S Pen features that
evolved from year to year with a note I
may not use this thing much but when I
do it's kind of nice so the plan itself
is now much more sensitive to different
levels of pressure the tip is smaller so
it feels like writing with an actual pen
instead of like a marker and it's now
designed so you definitely can't stick
it in backwards and break it oh yeah and
it's still clicky in case you're
wondering my favorite new S Pen feature
is the ability to screen capture
instantly and then convert it into a
jiff that you can share super useful and
actually really fun plus you still have
all the capture and drawing tools from
before so even with all these added
features overall performance on the note
7 is pretty much always on point as you
would expect from high-end specs like
this I say pretty much though because
every once in a while like I would wake
it up and try to start using it and it
would just lag a lot for no reason for a
couple seconds before it would snap out
of it I don't really know why it still
does this like it's gotten a few
software updates to possibly fix it but
it still does this sometimes so I got to
mention it but anyway when it's not
doing that its handling everyday use
like a beast it's super smooth and
snappy multiple apps open at the same
time swapping between them browsing a
lot of gaming a lot all that stuff no
problem the one thing a lot of heavy use
will hit though is definitely your
battery life this actually has a smaller
battery than the galaxy s7 edge even
though it's a bigger phone because it
has that slot in the side for the stylus
so smaller battery and bigger screen on
the front so
the battery life on the note seven is
really just about average it used to be
that phone that everyone took to CES and
everyone took two shows and long road
trips because it was that phone that had
a massive battery and it was removable
both of those things are no longer the
case I can definitely still get my three
hours of screen on time with my heavy
high brightness above average use but I
definitely have to charge it every night
I never really end a day with like 30%
left or anything I'm pretty much always
looking for a charger by the end of the
day anyway there are a bunch of other
little things that make the note 7 a
great phone still for a power user it
has fast charging which i think is kind
of underrated the best fast charging
phones are like life savers to me
it has wireless charging still it has
USB type-c which I like and a headphone
jack of course and there's expandable
storage as well via microSD and the
whole phone is also now water-resistant
its ip67 certified so this is the first
year that the Galaxy Note gets this
extra durability and that's really
awesome to see I feel like people don't
really appreciate how difficult it is to
water seal a phone from the inside
without affecting the outside like we've
seen water-resistant phones before
that's not new but they all look like
water-resistant phones whether they have
like a flap or something weird that just
doesn't look that good this pretty much
has the same exact design as you would
expect so that's a nice bonus the only
part that I would say actually does
suffer from the waterproofing is the
speaker that's speaker on the bottom
it's pretty weak and it's small and easy
to block and it's not super loud I mean
pretty much all waterproof or
water-resistant phones have some fault
or difficulty with the speaker that's
just a hard thing to do but I think
Samsung doesn't really have a big
problem with this because previous
Samsung phones have had pretty lousy
speakers anyway so it gets moderately
loud but it's pretty tinny and distorted
when it gets that loud so yeah it's
that's probably the worst part of the
phone right there now of course we got
to address the elephant in the room
you've probably been thinking about it
this whole review and that would be
explosions no matter how good a phone is
if a hundred of them explode within a
month of it being out you yeah no that's
that's pretty bad you kind of messed out
so the note 7 has a bit of reputation
now I get it it's really easy to make
jokes about how but the the main
officially the main issue was with the
battery overheating while charging
especially in like hot environments like
a car outside or while using third party
chargers while the batteries would
actually swell up to the point where
some of them would literally explode so
what Samsung did was offer a full
voluntary recall which was kind of rocky
you probably know about the way carriers
work in the United States but they kind
of did what they can but now so when
they're selling note sevens you know you
have one of the batch that isn't at risk
of exploding if it has a little green
battery indicator on the front that is
one of the new batch so if you're on
like a flight or something and the
flight attendant says hey is that a note
seven you got to power that down for the
flight at least you can point and be
like hey this is one of the new ones so
it actually won't explode my never
exploded but that doesn't mean it would
never have done anything weird so I did
return it if you have an old one you
should to get a new one I did and now
we're all good so assuming we're talking
about the new note sevens the ones that
are now being sold with the green
battery indicator this is the best phone
that Samsung makes right now for sure
I'll write alongside the galaxy s7 edge
which I think it can be a toss-up for
which phone is better for certain people
this one is a little bit bigger has a
little bit of a bigger display but it's
got it's just chock-full of features it
is stuffed to the gills and it is still
a power users phone it's also pricey but
I would say it's also worth the price to
have the best camera in any smartphone
the best display in any smartphone and
one of the best experiences that Samsung
has ever put together in the Android
world overall could recommend this phone
again
get the new one get the green battery
and you're set either way that's been it
thank you for watching this Galaxy Note
7 review hope you enjoyed if you have
any comments if we leave them below
right below that like button and of
course thank you for subscribing for
those of you who are to see the next
videos that are coming up again thanks
for watching talk to you guys the next
one peace
[Music]